[Applaudissements]
aux associations merci aussi avec eux
les élus pour les associations les
familles doivent prendre toute leur
responsabilités en appelant tous les
parents à la responsabilité l'autorité
parentale et capitales il est important
pour les études de tous que la
responsabilité parentale puisse
pleinement s'exercer j'ai donné au
gouvernement les moyens d'agir dans la
première ministre cet après-midi prendre
une série de
prendre la procédure et il est
indépendant aussi du magistrat c'est ça
qui permet de faire tourner
l'organisation judiciaire correctement
alors monsieur le ministre pour attirer
votre attention
ils ont un peu détourné une chanson et
je suis sûr que vous allez reconnaître
ça fait au dit moi
regarde-moi je ne sais plus comment
aimer mon boulot de greffier parle-moi
je ne sais plus pourquoi
continuer monsieur le député se sont
exprimés devant les tribunaux
ça fait quoi de se faire fumer
hein ça fait quoi de se faire fumer
ça fait quoi
tu peux pas tenir mon gars
et ouais mon garçon tu peux pas te dire
c'est dans le rétro de ta place
chacun doit respecter les règles chacun
doit savoir que l'on ne viole pas
impunément la loi je vous donne avec la
plus grande fermeté
injustifiable qui n'ont aucune
légitimité
attends on va attendre qu'il vient on va
attendre qu'il y a c'est mon gars lui
tu peux pas tenir garçon
tu peux pas tenir
tu peux pas te dire regarde il est pas
d'accord
dis-leur que tu peux pas tenir
il me fait tenir